hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint moins vite
sur messenger première catégorie on va
parler du chroniqueur qui a pris une
grosse vanne dans les dents et qui a dû
passer chez le dentiste pour s'en
remettre
regardez les nobles matthieu delormeau
pour s'être fait tacler par une
marionnette et j'aimerais bien poser une
question à jean marc si vous le
permettez web a profité pour parce que
j'ai il viendra pas sur nrj12 ou bien
c'est bon pourquoi pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils s'appellent jean marc c'est ce
que note que c'était trop con
villers days pour s'être pris une
réflexion dit ça tombe bien vous avez
extraordinaire vous estimez que je dis
n'importe quoi avant que je prononce la
phrase quand même hallucinant ce que
souvent si tu ne porteras et thierry
mots pour cette reprise vannes de cyril
hanouna
j'ai fait une déclaration d'amour à
tirer vos routes allant dans la loge à
l'europe avons tiré mon briquet la
politique me suis pas senti menacé
tout ce beau je sens que vous allez me
trouver des gueux l'avions fait partie
des dégueulasse retardé pas là
aujourd'hui mais nous a laissé son
enveloppe bien entendu mokhtar qui sera
de retour demain puisque vous le savez
que le mercredi mokhtar à centre aéré si
je dois aller chercher juste après
l'émission
bien entendu attention et mokhtar fermé
bien les enveloppes
apparemment il les a bien léché merci je
reconnais bien là la langue de mokhtar
la mortagne à mokhtar langues
le gadio est sur son petit chéri mon
chéri
[Applaudissements]